good morning Hank it's Tuesday January
27th I'm in the fifth week of my office
reorganization project and as you can
see it's going swimmingly hey today's
video comes to you in two very special
parts part one the best New Year's
resolution ever happy new year
streamers Hank the best New Year's
resolution ever happy new year's
streamers is a book that I wrote when I
was a child that I've discovered during
my office reorganisation project three
years ago on New Year's Day everybody in
my family had to make one new year's
resolution I hated that mom why us
because Hank if we can take just one
second away from the story I'd like to
explore the whole question of this
staircase to nowhere when I was a kid
growing up in Orlando Florida I believe
that the definition of rich was that you
had stairs in your house like I believed
in the whole direct relationship between
richness and stairs so completely that I
thought that the IRS like came to your
house every year and was like how many
stairs you got and you were like 13 and
they were like that'll be $20,000
alright back to the story now my mother
promised to clean out the drawers she
hasn't done that since we left Michigan
in 26 mom there is little brown things
dad promised away under 600 pounds that
would be a miracle I promised a weigh
under 600 pounds but dad that's what you
promised last year by the way note that
you can tell that is fat due to his
belly
my brother promised to take a bath he
smells like a skunk at the bottom of the
stairs like a typical poor kid Hank's
like I'll take a bath and then at the
top of the stairs little mr. rich pants
says you've never done that and me well
I promise to try my hardest Bravo thank
you and out of all the resolutions mine
was the only one to come true
yay and then you can see the stairs that
lead up to the top of the podium
what has the first podium slot oh it's
me the end oh my god I'm so sorry I mean
dad you're not fat mom there is no
little brown things in the cabinets and
Hank you don't smell well actually you
could stand to take more showers part to
the reinvigoration of the Ning Hank the
Ning has been suffering from a little
bit of neglect so much so that in fact
many people watching this video are
probably saying what's the Ning link in
the sidebar
and I think I've come to the conclusion
that we just can't run the Ning by
ourselves Hank what we need is some Ning
masters Ning masters
one word to say it's like all the best
parts of a ringmaster except you not to
get eaten by lions
so nerdfighters starting soon there will
be a few Ning masters they're going to
feature new content on the main page of
the Ning they're going to organize and
moderate the crazy name forums and
they're generally just going to raise up
the awesome levels of the Ning if you
are a committed made of awesome
nerdfighter who would like to be an ink
master apply by creating a blog post
telling me why you should be an ink
master and then I will pick a few of my
favorites and those people will become
Ning masters also even if you do not
want to be an ink master if you do want
to share your creative awesome with
other people on the Ning start making
blog posts in fact even if you're
uploading photos and videos try to
upload them as blog posts because that
makes it much more likely that we can
feature them on the front page ok I got
to go back to writing the Paper Towns
screenplay Hey
thanks for being awesome nerdfighters oh
my gosh you're so great